okay so today's classic interview I'm
gonna mention his name but it's not
about Jordan Peterson okay this is a
classic interview we filmed back in June
of 2014 with Amy Johnson who's a
psychologist and life coach and I
present this interview to you today not
to make this a story about Jordan
Peterson I know a lot of people in the
audience don't like it when I talk about
Jordan Peterson and we probably have
already spoken about him enough this
week but just because a lot of our
perspectives on so-called self help and
advice for life have been sort of
subjugated and hijacked by the quote
teachings of people like Jordan Peterson
I thought it would be a good week to go
back to when I spoke to Amy Johnson
again psychologists and life coach this
is a sort of different approach to the
world of understanding the world around
us and figuring out how to exist within
it and life advice and all that type of
stuff so even though this isn't about
Jordan Peterson maybe just think about
how Amy's approach compares and
contrasts to much of what we see young
men adhering to and falling for in 2018
I'm joined today by dr. Amy Johnson
who's a psychologist life coach and
author her website is dr. Amy Johnson
dot-com it's really great to have you I
came across a couple of your articles
online and thought you might be a good
person to have a conversation with about
some of the recent trends that we're
seeing in the I don't even know what to
call it maybe that's a good place to
start what do you call this trend of
websites and kind of the desire for
knowledge around self-realization
enlightenment mindfulness what what do
you call this entire area right now oh
gosh I don't like calling it self-help
or anything right that sort of implies
the fact that we are broken and need
help but it's certainly you know I like
the word enlightenment personally it's a
you know some words kind of resonate
more than others but I wouldn't call it
self oh well it seems like 10 15 maybe
even closer to 20 year
this trend started around what I would
call kind of logistical help right which
was looking at the specifics of yoga and
meditation and a very kind of
nuts-and-bolts approach to feeling
better or whatever the case may be
and now in the last five or so years
there's been a lot more focus on what's
really what's the goal of all this stuff
that we're doing right as opposed to how
do you do a yoga pose more about well
what what is good work-life balance what
are the trends and socio in in culture
in the United States that maybe are
leading to left less satisfaction with
one's life do you see the same trend the
move away from the specifics of the yoga
or pilates and more an idea of how how
are our day-to-day lives affecting us
longer-term I definitely do I really
like that you'd say that I don't I
haven't heard many people really kind of
call it out explicitly but you know I
think for a long time it was about tools
and techniques it was all about like the
next cool thing to do and now it's like
okay everyone's looking back just like
you said saying okay well we've been
doing all this stuff but why what's it
for and what's it getting us you know
which is a excellent place to be because
we can all just go out and do a bunch of
cool stuff but what is it getting us and
I think it really kind of kind of points
toward this bigger desire to just like
have a more peaceful enjoyable
experience on the planet you know and
however that looks for you if it's if
it's more about success and achievement
or more about slowing down or speeding
up it's different for everyone but
seeing that all of those tools and
techniques of the past decade or so you
know are are all kind of pointing us
toward some bigger goal that you know
whatever that is for us in your
experience as a psychologist what trend
are you seeing in terms of what seems to
have people enjoying their lives less
than maybe they would like to because
you know I I deal with politics quite a
bit on this program and it would be very
easy to think if you're aware of what's
happening politically in this country or
around the world that could be a
reasonable cause for dissatisfaction but
my view is very skewed because most
people aren't as involved in
politics as we are do you see it as
something systemic right is it media and
and the phone the smartphone culture
always with you and creating these kind
of constant comparisons to what your
friends on social media are doing is it
some other type of of work-life balance
thing I mean what do you see as the big
problem right now
so those things you mentioned I see is
even kind of just smaller pieces of it
and I think it's even bigger than
anything specific like that and it is a
misunderstanding about where our
experience comes from so I grew up
believing that in order if I wanted to
have a happy life I had to go to college
and marry a person that I was always
going to be happy with and get the right
job and do all of those things and I
think most people believe that in some
form or another and so we're constantly
constantly looking for what do I do
what do I get where do I go on vacation
or even how do I meditate what self-help
book do I read what you know what do I
do
trying to feel good and we're just
simply looking in the wrong direction
the increase in inequality that is very
obvious when you consume any amount of
popular culture and use me etc is
something that I've talked about with a
financial blogger in the past and he has
kind of suggested to me that when it
comes to what you're really kind of
getting at I think is one's place in
life both educationally relationship
wise and financially that there's the
kind of treadmill that exists where as
soon as you achieve a new accomplishment
whether it is a relationship whether it
is a raise and you're making more money
no matter what it is that you achieve we
are in a way immediately then
establishing a new baseline or barometer
for our lives and still then looking to
the next thing and I fall into this as
well with this program right which is
every time we set a goal for the show
and and you know knock on wood so far we
achieve those goals immediately I start
thinking of the next thing and it's this
constant treadmill that doesn't really
allow you to just say okay now is when
I'm in a good place
yeah absolutely and it's you know again
a big part of that is the
misunderstanding that okay when I hit
this mark whatever that is then I'm
gonna feel a certain way right we tied
the mark to how we feel when they're not
really related it's not like I mean yeah
pirata marathon or you hit some big
business milestone sure you're gonna be
happy for a little while but that is not
where sustainable long term peace of
mind and happiness come from at all and
so we're just on this treadmill of like
oh the next thing and then we hit the
goal we don't feel the way we thought
we'd feel so we think well maybe that
was the wrong goal maybe I didn't really
want this I wanted this other thing so
then we're all running after the next
day has this existed as long as humans
have I mean I I because we I only exist
now right so it's very hard for me to
say well this is a dynamic this is this
is a phenomena that would have been
observed twenty thirty thousand years
ago for humans on the one hand humans
have not changed all that much in recent
time but at the same time we have a
completely unique life situation right
now the day-to-day concerns for life are
so different now than they were ten
thousand years ago I wonder about that
I do too that's an excellent question I
I don't know I would love to go back to
cute man days and see what their minds
did you know and what they thought about
ahead and goals and all of that I mean I
think clearly our society today doesn't
help so you know but the extent to which
it creates this or maybe just magnifies
it I'm not sure it's a great question
though do you get the sense that there's
this trend now where online there are so
many websites that are putting together
articles which clearly do really well
but I question what the actual value of
them and these are you know 10 things
you will definitely regret in life if
you don't do now in this kind of
compartmentalization making lists of
wait it's not almost like a self-help
list craze do you think that it's good
in the sense that it's opening up people
to issues they may not consider it all
or do you think the net effect is
negative because it's really kind of
putting things together in a way that
may not really be that useful to people
so I'll give you a psychologist answer
that has nothing to with matter-of-fact
because I have no clue but I think
you need to pay attention to how it
feels because I really think it can be
either I mean I've seen those on
Facebook too and sometimes it's like oh
yeah I hadn't thought of that and it
really does do something good and other
times you feel horrible so it's so you
know they the list crack me up I don't
think that across the board they're
helpful and I don't think the cross the
board they're hurtful but I think each
person really needs to pay attention and
just like you know how does it feel to
you and it's something you want to be
thinking about right now all right we've
been speaking with dr. Amy Johnson she's
a psychologist life coach and author you
can check out her website at dr. Amy
Johnson dot-com great to have you on
today thanks for joining us thank you
great